I would like to accept Islam and I would
uh want you to help me to recite the
Kalma Mah the sister Nali she's from
Puna working in MNC and she wants to
accept Islam sister before you accept
Islam I would like to make sure that is
anyone forcing you to accept Islam
sister uh no brother I've been reading
about Islam since a year now so I
thought uh this is the best opportunity
for me Mah is anyone forcing you no is
there any economic pressure no is there
any physical pressure no because in
Islam forcing anyone to accept Islam is
prohibited in Islam number one it's
living priv in this country that's
number two but if someone wants to
accept Islam willingly no one can
prevent you from and inshallah as your
desire is I will read the kma and inshah
you can repeat it
yes and I'd like to ask you before that
do you believe that there is one God yes
do you believe that idol worship is
prohibited yes I do do you believe that
the last and final messenger is Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him yes I do Mah
sister so I'll just recite theama and
you can repeat after
me Ashu Ashu Allah
allaha illah
muham
muhamd
ABD I bear witness I bear witness that
that there is no God there is no God but
Allah but Allah and I bear witness and I
bear witness that that Prophet Muhammad
prophet Muhammad is is the servant the
servant and the messenger and the
messenger of Allah of Allah mashallah
sister you're a Muslim thank you and may
Allah subhana tala reward you and I pray
to Allah subh Grant you jna it's good
that you have been studying Islam for
one year and it is good you read the
Quran and the Hadith otherwise if you
have seen the media maybe you have never
accepted Islam so I pray to Allah
subhana wa tala that may accept your
effort and inshallah Grant J thank you s
thank
you yes
brother har Krishna
my name is ravikant Pand I'm 23 years
old I have completed my graduation from
Kolkata University I belong to sonat
Dharma so I have no qualification to
speak in the front of you but I'm trying
to speak with you I have one question in
my mind and uh even I I can speak wrong
because I don't know English very much
well so please forgive me problem uh my
question in sanat Dharma is also written
he woman should be protect in a Child
Time by his parents and a young Time by
his husband and after the mother his
Elder son will protect two woman in
Sarma says there is no love in this
world is lust is there in this world so
love and lust is two different thing and
if you it cannot be go in a same one
platform so our real duy is to engage
the service of the Lord and in a sanatan
Dharma Arjuna asked one time to Krishna
oh Krishna please tell me what this man
are is speaking I don't know I I don't
know so many languages so please clarify
me so Krishna told to Arjuna they are
talking like a frog even a snack come
and they eat just like I come by death
and I eat so in this world there is no
love we are trying to satisfy it
this is a simply attachment we can say
in sanat Dharma says woman attached with
a man and man attached with a woman so
uh this sanatan Dharma because in bhagat
Gita 5,200 years ago came and 2,800
years ago in a Bible came and 14400
years ago your Quran came so sanatan
Dharma is coming by so many millions of
year so I I belongs to I am not
justifying our life is meant for simply
engage the service of what's your
question brother I've read the San I
give my comments on sanatan to you I
want to ask you what is the question do
you want to say that sanatan Hinduism
also protects the women no I am asking
so our life our duty is to satisfi the
woman or satisfi the Lord or engage the
service of the Lord the brother as the
question is our duty to satisfy the
woman or to satisfy Lord yeah the
brother has the question that what is
our duty to satisfy the woman there is
love that is lust or to satisfy almighty
God before I come to youran I will tell
what Islam says as Allah says in the
Quran I said my talk in Sur room chter
number 30 verse number 21 that Allah
subhana tala has created for you made
from amongst yourself so that you may
dwell in tranquility and he has put love
and mercy between your hearts that means
Allah has created for you of your nature
mates your wives your spouses so that
you may dwell in them Tranquility you
get Tranquility you get calmness and
almighty God has put love between your
hearts once our beloved Prophet wasallam
said that
even having
sex with your wife it is
Charity sa asked even having sex is
Charity how so the the reply came
because you are having it
lawfully if you have it unlawfully with
the woman who's not your wife it becomes
prohibited so because you're enjoying
lawfully even that is Charity that is
that's a good
deed so having sex with your wife also
almighty God rewards you and you rightly
said that there is love and there is
lust I too have read sanatan DH and I
appreciate the Oneness of god mentioned
sanatan DH you know Hinduism has got
various different sects you may be aware
of that various different denominations
the highest scripture there is shti and
the smti shti according Hindu scripture
means the word of God and vas are the
highest they believe in one God they
believe almighty God has got no images I
can give quotations you can see my video
cassette similarities between Islam and
Hinduism but should we satisfy the woman
or should we satis y God number one I
said in my talk the basic aim of every
human being whether man or woman should
be to satisfy almighty
God now while satisfying almighty God
you may satisfy the woman you may not
satisfy if she's a good Pi woman she'll
be satisfied if you are satisfying
almighty
God for example almighty God says have
sex only with your wife a pi woman who a
m will be happy but a lustful woman she
will not be happy
she is the why following God follow me
she may Bean she may be a footstep of
the devil you ask me questions about
Krishna that Krishna gave advice to
Arjun since you mentioned
Krishna he's supposed to be a role model
for the Hindus and we read in
Mahabharat you know I've given the talk
on similarities but because you asked
this question what we read in Mahabharat
that when Krishna when he goes on the
bank of the
river very often when the woman used to
go to have a bath he used to take the
clothes away and run away for
what For Love or for lust because he is
God he can do suppose I am honor of I if
God would like to Rob clothes of women
and none away to see them coming out
okay come out without clothes then why
can't you and I
do if you can copy God why can't you
copy God if we see if you know this is
the
ultimate see we cannot copy God because
God is a different level but if you
consider Krishna to be God and if God is
doing something like taking away clothes
of the woman and telling them come out
without clothes can you do that or not
you can do it very easily that's what we
find in Hindi the movies you know we
find all this what I'm trying to say we
should take the message which is right I
read the San DH there are many things
which are good hundreds of good things
thousands of good things but what is not
good you have to leave it
aside I've given a talk on similarities
between Islam and Hinduism now you speak
about Krishna talk about love talk about
lust I appreciate many things of
Christian but not
everything many things he said is right
he tells that be a shatra fight against
Injustice even be against your
relatives he says that in bhagad Gita
chapter number two verse number
31 same thing in the Quran 4 135 that
stand up for justice as witness to Allah
subhana wa ta'ala even if you be against
yourself against your relatives against
your father or mother Allah protect smth
so if what he's saying matches with my
Quran with the real word of almighty God
I accept it but everything I don't
accept it to be the word of God that's
the reason what I
do this is the
fan fan is the criteria to judge right
from wrong and if you read this this is
the last and Fin final revelation of
almighty God which was revealed to
humanity if you read this I challenge
you to take out a single mistake in this
the other books that we
have the other religious scriptures
because of passage of time they have
been changed interpolation concoction
who says that not I the scholars of
Christianity they say that the Bible has
not been maintained in the true form the
scholars of Mahabharat say that
initially Mahabharat was a story told by
the grandfather of Arjun to the people
later on the 8,000 shlokas became 24,000
shlokas now we have more than 100,000
shlokas interpolation addition so what
has been added I cannot accept that God
Almighty leave us at God even the
prophet of God can do such things so
what I say this may be an
interpolation I respect the messengers
of God but if you say that these people
are saintly people no saintly people
will do what I consider Okay this may be
an interpolation this may be a
concoction so therefore I request you to
read a book which is 100% pure without
any interpolation Allah has promised in
the Quran in Surah chapter number 15
verse number n that we have revealed the
Quran and we shall Guard from corruption
almighty God has taken him upon himself
that he will prevent any corruption in
it from this if you read you get the
pure rights that the woman can have in
this world hope that answer the question
brother
may we have the next question from the G
side in the
rare this is U Shar here I'm so grateful
to the irf that we get this opportunity
to ask you some questions and for the
first time I've uh seen you and I'm glad
that I can ask you a simple question I
am a
businessman and one of my rather my only
hobby is uh studying religions so one of
them obviously being the Quran so my
question is fairly simple like um I
really liked what you spoke about Aisha
that was a very uh wonderful thing that
you said so um my question is fairly
simple I'll make it very small but I
really hope that I have the opportunity
to cross question you after you answer
me on your answer gred thank
you so uh we see in Muslim uh book
Number Four number 2127 wherein it says
a part of it that is uh he stuck me
Aisha on the chest which caused me pain
uh further down if you look at mishkat
Al masabi Volume 2 page number 690
repeated again in Muslim book number n
number 3506 aart of it I'll just get to
the point where an Omar is trying to say
to the prophet or trying rather trying
to make him laugh he says messenger of
God I wish you had seen the daughter of
karij where she asked me for extra money
and I got up and slapped her on the neck
God's messenger laughed and said they
are around me as you see asking for
extra money Abu Bakr then got up went to
Aisha and slapped her on the neck and
Umar did the same to Hava now we see
something of a pattern coming in then um
if you just jump to Quran chapter 4
verse 34 and those wives you fear may be
rebellious admonish banish them to the
couches and beat them now as I
understand from your talk and that there
is equal punishment for both man and
woman I'm not contending whether they
should be beaten or not my point is um
what is the right of the woman if the
man is wrong because he gets to beat her
up asked a very good question and I give
you the right to cross question me after
the answer it's granted
the brother quoted Hadith of Muslim and
Mishi do you know the relationship
between H andar well I've not really got
to the point that much I'm still
studying do you know the relationship of
AA and Abu Bakr with them both her
father if I'm not mistaken that's
right I asking you a question are you
married yes yes do you have a daughter
two of them two of them fine I get to go
to heaven sorry I get to go to heaven no
if you bring them up correctly I
remember with love and compassion then
you'll go to heaven
otherwise but just kidding just K but
that is only righteous de without demand
you can't enter jna so for you to go to
heaven besides upbringing your two
daughters correctly you have to follow
the laws of the Quran and the and be a
believer understand that we'll discuss
after answer to you I understand after
answer inshallah I'm asking a simple
question suppose your daughter if she
wants to jump from a 10 story building
what will you do I'll stop
her if she adamant what will you do
Point yeah you get the point very good
if you to jump no I want to go I want to
fly like
Superman dad you are preventing me from
being a Superman what will you do well
I'll uh I'll stop her obviously will you
slap her or not if if if required he
said now to jump what will you
do well I I can ask the other way around
I'm asking if she wants to jump from the
10 story I will hit her if required not
normally you
say one FL a father is cruel to be kind
yes now our beloved Prophet mam said
anyone who does not love Allah and his
messenger more than his own life he's
not a
Muslim
anyone who does not love Allah and his
messenger more than his own life he's
not a Muslim so there are many occasions
what happened that sometimes they were
disrespectful to the husband not a
normal husband Prophet Muhammad Salli
wasallam there were many occasions not
one occasion there are many occas may
Allah pleas with him and abak may Allah
pleas with him when they came to know
that one of the wives has caused pain to
the prophet
they were the father-in-law of the
Prophet but they love the prophet not
only more than their daughter they love
the prophet more than their own life
there are many occasions which occasion
you are referring to I don't know there
were occasions when they came to know
that my daughter has caused pain to the
prophet of Allah how dare she does it
they being father they have the right to
slap not you and me for us
they they are the mother of the
Believers but yet they were human beings
even the wives of the Prophet though
they were wives of the Prophet they are
the best example yet they were human
beings and they did make mistakes like
the Ayah recited by the 432 they want
equal rights they ver inab chter 33
where the wies of the Prophet tell the
prophet why don't you give us the luxury
of this world they objected why are we
undergoing such a life of poverty so
Allah sends a revelation if you want
this world I will grant it to you but
you you will not get
Jenna the verse of the Quran says I will
free you that means if you want I will
let you go free divorce not that he
divorced and you can get the luxury of
this world but you won't get heaven in
the yearafter and the wives of the
Prophet they repented and they asked for
forgiveness and Allah forgive them so
here also it's in
context and going against the prophet is
more bad than jumping from
Top jumping from Top your daughter will
kill herself that's it correct but going
against the prophet is more
bad did you get the answer um sir but my
question still stands I understood your
point I haven't complete man okay you
ask the question no problem my my
question is uh pretty simple I haven't
complete man yet brother all right
because I know your question was in two
parts then you quoted the verse of the
Quran 434 yeah and said about wife
beating I to complete that before you
answer other you said I answered half I
only answered one part of a question
regarding Hadith they said second part
is of Surah n 4 number 34 exactly after
the verse that was recited by thei after
ver which
says that the men are the Protectors of
the women the verse says that if they're
disobedient if the disobedient then
don't talk to
her after that don't share the bed then
the Arabic word is d means beat her
lightly the Arabic word is beat her
lightly Allah be peace with him said
when you beat your wife you should not
beat on the face Point number one point
number two when you beat your wife there
should be no Mark left on a
body and he gave example beating with a
miswak miswak is
toothbrush in modern way I will say
beating with a
handkerchief handkerchief now if you
beat your wife with a
handkerchief it is symbolic it is not
wife bashing wife bashing is not around
in Islam wife bashing means one sh on
the face hit so hard so that the mark
remains she'll remember you for the next
one week or two weeks in Islam wife
bashing is prohibited it is daaba means
beat her lightly that means first you
tell her she's wrong you admonish her
don't share the bed with her ultimatum
last warning beat her lightly now what I
said for any crime committed the
punishment is same punishment is same
beating lightly is not a punishment it's
a warning
can you do the
opposite can the daughter hit the father
what if your daughter slaps you will you
like it no why
equality let me
man you talk about equality if your
daughter slaps you will you like it no
no there may be occasion when you get
lunatic when you become very old and if
you want to jump and then she slaps you
I will agree with her correct though you
said no I'm agreeing you I understand
I'm helping you you understand but you
don't understand me no I I'm helping you
okay if you grow up and become a lunatic
you become Sile you want to jump from
the 10 story your daughter don't do
father she may have to slap you she's
doing in good faith accepted right now
here where a husband is giving a warning
to the wife if the wife does the same
what will the retaliation be imagine
suppose a big there a massive person
bodybuilder comes and ask Mash with you
if a small man come maybe you'll hit him
a mash person aner comes and tells you
something will you hit
him will you hit him no though you may
have lot of guts but or no why similarly
since Allah says in the previous verse
man has been given more strength than
the woman so a physical warning a
symbolic warning a man can give to a
woman a woman can't give to a man a
woman can't there are other things
there are other things she can do such
as such as for example if she has to
cook food in the house it's the duty of
the husband to get Market she can refuse
to cook if you don't get Market I will
not cook she can
object very
well she can object saying I will not
cook it's an
objection on her part if for example
he's not offering Salah off Salah is
important she can
object nicely with love and affection my
dear husband he's offer Salah then she
may get little bit angry also no problem
getting angry with husband is not
allowed unless it's for the sake of
Allah
and but not physical she can't get
physical if she get physical there will
be retaliation it will never
work imagine your wife slapping you will
you live her fine you may so what do you
realize this is a symbolic beating what
the Western media has done they Port as
though wife bashing where bashing you
know the also so because of that
Islam is the best way of life it shows
you how to lead life with your wives
also hope that answer the question if
you have any counter question I'm most
welcome brother Yes actually two points
on that primarily the first thing that
you said is a daaba uh which means
basically tapping and as I understand
from the hands word dictionary um the it
comes from the word ID now if you look
at it the Arabic word is used in two
ways one to strike up a poem the word ID
which from which the word Dara is uh
taken out uh the first is to strike up a
poem and the second which is used 12
times in the
Quran phical action of strike strike off
strike up a poem or second poem strike
up a poem The metaphorically second part
is the physical action of striking it's
used again in uh Surah 812 wherein it um
about an angel strike off their heads
strike off the very tips of their
fingers the same word is used so how can
the same word be interpreted there as
lightly but here as very good question
the second part very good question very
good question the second part part is
that if we come back to sah bukari
Volume 7 number
715 again uh the respectable I truly
mean that uh respectable woman Aisha a
great scholar I read about her uh
narrated Aisha said that a lady came
wearing a green Veil and complained to
her that is Aisha and showed her a green
spot on her skin caused by beating it
was the Habit at that time for women to
support each other means when they get
beaten up so you support each other so
when Allah messenger came Aisha said I
have not seen any woman suffering as
much as a believing woman look her skin
is greener than her
clothes that was my second part as for
second part I answer first and first
part answer second no problem she's
complaining to the prophet that somebody
has done Injustice to her it doesn't end
saying the prophet agreed with
it if someone has Injustice if we read
ahead in some other Hadith the prophet
may have done Justice to her it doesn't
say that someone beat her and the
prophet agreed with it correct she's
just reporting that maybe there is
Injustice done to a woman that's it the
moment she's complaining means she's
disagreeing with it she didn't say
Prophet I had a very good thing I saw
that the woman were beaten up the moment
she's complaining means the wife has
Aisha M be with her disapproved of it so
the lesson we get from this is no one
should beat the woman such a way that
she becomes green but sir U see the
exact statement she makes is that I have
not seen any woman that's Aisha herself
it's not my interpretation I've not seen
any woman suffering as much as the
believing woman so we see at the time of
Muhammad um that women were really H in
very very bad shape even though you know
you know there Hadith is saying I have
not seen a person a believing person
like hasz B suffering what was he
suffering from his master tortured him
and said don't say there's one God and I
will leave you B may Allah be peace with
him on the death St he agreed to die he
will say I will not denounce Allah I
will keep on saying Muhammed there's no
God but Allah and Prophet Muhammad is a
messenger he's taking the pain that
means if I say hasz B is a believer who
being tortured that does not mean that
what act that been done on B may Allah
be peace with him is right it is wrong
but he's a Believer who's taking the
pain in this context we have to see the
context and go to the
Shar we have to see fi and what was the
woman was she what was she who tortured
her was it the master was she a slave
woman you have to go to the Shar I'm not
a mad I'm telling you what the answer
can be you have to go to the Shar and
find out why was she who hit her who
beat her did the husband do was the
husband a Believer there are 10,000
reasons but just because excuse me in
mishkat Al brother volume brother sh
what I would like you to do there are so
many people waiting at all the mics
precisely concisely I'd like you to put
your question in a few words and then
close because you got such a big sheath
of papers there are many people I see
waiting with small slips or something so
we cannot allow this whole thing to go
on this is not a debate session it's a
question
session I want you to put your question
in the next four sentences let Dr Zakir
answer so that all the many ladies
standing there here also get a chance we
have exactly 1 hour 12 minutes left we
have occupied 20 minutes already brother
initially you asked two question
answered you said I want a counter what
counter you gave in the counter you're
asking one more question I don't mind
answering you 100 questions but in this
rule one question at time go behind the
que no problem you ask two questions the
answer you s out a counter question with
the counter question you asking one more
question so you know I'm very kind I
don't mind I would love after finish you
can come in the cabin and inshallah I
will answer all your question I want to
ask you after I answer your question
what will you do will you believe in the
religion has AA believed yes or no I yet
have to answer your counter question
well it's not just this one point there
are many many more I'll answer inshallah
all how many are there 10 20 50 100 how
many well we can sit on that how many
approximately well there are many more
I'm not how many 10 20 100,000 10,000
how many do you have now in your mind
well I do have how many 10 20 30 how
many probably quite a few maybe quite a
few is how much five or 10 approximately
I don't maybe 100 questions 100
questions you have brother after the
session is over we sit together okay
write down all the 100 questions
inshallah
inshallah I will try and answer everyone
okay I request you we'll spend the full
night
together I don't mind because you are a
seeker of Truth and I'm also a seeker of
Truth and my job is to try and clarify
the truth not that I'm a scholar I will
try and answer all the 100 questions but
I doubt whether you'll be able to write
100 questions I doubt coming to your
main counter question brother that will
be basic counter question counter
question of yours is that the has got
two meanings one is stke off the head
you ask me then how do you come to know
which is correct correct exactly in the
counter question don't ask one more
question that means they breaking the
rule sir I'm just refuting what you said
not
refuting see you asked the counter
question counter question was of daaba
has got meaning of striking that is a
counter question in that counter
question you ask one more question you
can't ask one more question in a counter
question you can ask one counter
question but that was a fresh question
that you asked now coming to your
question of daaba you said striking I
agree with you how do you come to know
one time it is lightly beating one time
it is striking off the head you know the
verse in the Quran is there in
suram Chapter
19 Verse number
47 Mary may Allah be pleased with her
she says when Archangel Gabriel says
that you shall have a son so she says
how shall I have a son when no man
touched
me how shall I have a son when no man
has touched me now if you go to the L
your hands wear
dictionary all Lanes I believe read my
dictionaries all the on Internet it's
not difficult you go on the internet and
type you get 100 questions against Islam
100 you get thousand very easy not that
a person had done research if you had
done research you have come to know who
was whose father and who was his husband
and mother everything but you go on the
internet you get this very easy now
the Arabic word masah has got two
meanings physical touch it means sexual
touch so when Mary M be pleas with her
she says how shall I have a son when no
man has touched me it is understood it
is not physical touch it is sexual touch
correct yes
similarly there are several verses in
the Quran now when there are two three
meanings even both can be correct or one
can be correct to have more details you
go to the Hadith Hadith is the
commentary of the the verse of the
Quran
correct maybe the same word has got two
meaning in that verse it means meaning
number one in the second verse in
meaning number two Hadith is a
commentary so when we go to the Hadith
of this Sur 4:34 talking about daaba
there the prophet said do not beat on
the
face do not leave a mark beat like a
toothbrush I gave the answer but you
were so much concentrating on the notes
you have that that you forgot my answer
if you have heard my answer that if
there are two three meanings all
meanings can not be
right maybe one is right maybe two are
right maybe all three are right
therefore you have to go back to the
prophet the Quran
says obey Allah and obey the messenger
so when there are two three meanings you
have to go to the Hadith and find out
what did the prophet mean by that word
so there when say strikes of that it
means strikes off here it means strike
lightly so therefore if you know the
supplement is the commentary of the
Quran it's the Hadith without the
authentic Hadith you canot understand
Islam so a prophet said it means beat
lightly like beating with a toothbrush
don't beat on the face don't leave a
mark on the body so these are the
guidance given by therefore it is
obligatory that besides the Quran you
have to follow the authentic Hadith hope
that answerers the question and
inshallah I'll wait for you after 10:00
in the speakers launch inshallah yes
brother Sher
thank you and and since you have two
daughters you said you have two
daughters and you want sorry and one son
the son there's no Hadith saying that
son will take your jna here if he become
the P son and if he prays for you
inshallah he will be a part to Jenna
what I want I want to see to it that
besides Good Deeds you even have
faith faith is one of the important
criteria to go to Jenna and since you
have an urge to go to Jenna to Paradise
inshah I pray to Allah subhana tala may
he make me the
the pathway to take you to J
inshah yes sister hi my name is Chloe
I'm from Canada I'm a student here in
Mumbai